let's bring in peter king football
morning in america one of the great
football writers of our generation peter
always a pleasure thank you so much for
joining us
dan thank you how are you i'm doing
great i'm doing great as
uh i was doing a little research for the
show
uh you know west coast time last night i
was saying man i hope i hope peter gets
his column out a little early so i can
read it before i go to bed
and you did thank you for that um you're
welcome
and uh i did it for you i know you did i
know you did so many so many anxiously
awaiting that column uh each
and every monday um obviously free
agency a big topic in that one the
the the patriots um
by far the the most aggressive team out
there you had a line in your uh
in your column that they had 175 million
in guarantees in two days which is
almost the same amount that robert kraft
paid for the team
when he bought it is that right
yeah and you know i think the other
part of that whole thing is just the
simple fact that
you know obviously bill belichick's
never done this before robert kraft has
never done this before and
look no matter what way you you spin it
um you know half of their team
will be different half of their starting
team
is going to be different from what it
was
four months ago and you know that
that includes big stars like johnny
smith who i think in that
offense is going to be a big start in it
and it also
includes returning stars like kyle van
noy who i still can't figure out why
miami uh paid him 15 million dollars for
14 games and then let him go
uh i still think he's a he's a force to
be reckoned with
uh and i you know look the patriots are
going to be
significantly improved we all know that
the question is all going to come down
to cam newton and what he has
left uh you know he sure looked like he
was limited
for a lot of last season uh he
was not throwing the ball well we'll see
if that was
covid related uh or whatever but
you know to me i think you know the one
missing piece now or the one piece that
we really don't know very much about
is uh what's going to happen at
quarterback so that's going to be the
little mystery p we will
yeah they bring cam back on a relatively
team-friendly deal especially
this era when starting quarterbacks or
you know making 30 plus million at least
the you know the top 10 guys
um you brought up a great point
half of their 22 starters are are going
to be new or
guys who have left and then come back
like van noy
who do you think is going to have the
biggest impact in terms of the new
free agents the the johnny smiths the
hunter henry's the you know the agalors
the kendrick porns
well i think i think i would combine
that and just say that to me
um the best the offense that bill
belichick really
loves playing josh mcdaniels the
offensive coordinator
the offense they love playing is very
tight and
friendly um and look
the the year it was 10 years ago now but
the year that they had a great offensive
season
uh centered around aaron hernandez and
rob gronkowski
now almost 10 years ago when
basically those guys combine to score
24 touchdowns right and
and it was that is what i think they
would really
love to get back to because you're
moving the chain
safely and you're doing it on
intermediate
throws to two sure-handed guys so that
is what i think we can really expect to
happen
and and really i think one of the
interesting parts about their offense
is they basically have not had
a tight end of any skill or substance
for the last two years
and so when you look at it that way and
you say this is what we like to do
best you know play two tight ends
in the game at the same time and they
don't have any or they at least
haven't had any i think it's going to be
revolutionarily different uh
for the patriots and it's going to allow
them
even if cam newton's downfield arm is
not what it was
i think it's going to allow them to be
able to consist consistently
move the chains yeah i think that's a
great point you know
historically teams that spend as big as
the patriots spent in free agency
it doesn't really go well but i feel
like because the patriots
uh this is the patriots it just it just
feels a little bit different to me
um and i i love i love both of those
tight ends very familiar with johnny
smith from his
you know days kind of backing up delaney
walker and uh
in tennessee and then he really came
into his own last year and went healthy
that's
that's a guy that is of the belichick
mold peter because he's a good blocker
as well similar to gronk in that
yeah and the other thing that the other
thing remember about john who smith
arthur smith the offensive coordinator
in tennessee
did exactly with johnny smith what
uh josh mcdaniels did a decade ago in
the playoff game against the tim tebow
broncos
he put aaron hernandez in the backfield
right and in a playoff game hernandez
ran for 70 or 80 yards and
johnny smith has done that and he's done
it well so
you know we'll see i think there's going
to be a few surprises in that new
england offense
speaking of surprises who surprised you
maybe for the moves that
that they didn't make or or that didn't
spend as much money
as you anticipated i
i credit teams for not spending money by
the way dan i think that
you know year after year after year
people get so excited on march 20th
march 22nd whatever and then
they are almost always uh
disappointed with what happens and what
ends up happening with the you know with
the money that they didn't spend
i mean i'll give you i'll give you a
team that that i think
should be getting significant credit
that's the indianapolis colts
because colts and you say
man they still need a really good
downfield uh receiving weapon
you don't know if they're going to get
t.y hilton back you've got
some uncertainty about whether michael
pittman is going to be
that guy i think they uh
they hope he is but they're not really
sure that he's going to be
a really 60
hey in that offense but what i give him
credit for is that
they've got three guys who
they need to pay big money to in the
next
year plus or or even before a year you
know quentin nelson
and braden smith the underrated right
tackle they have
everybody knows nelson and then also
darius leonard on defense
so you know that right there is i'm
gonna guess about 50 million dollars
average uh on the cap long term
you know for the next say three years
and
and so you don't want to just say hey we
got a lot of cap room let's go spend it
well if you spend a lot then you're
going to be
struggling to sign the homegrown talent
that you love
so i look at indianapolis in this
in the early days of free agency and say
i think their patience has been quite
smart now i would agree with that about
uh about the colts um let me ask you
about
deshaun watson uh three more women today
uh filed lawsuits there are now ten
civil suits filed
against the texans quarterback from
women who worked with him as a massage
therapist claiming that watson
sexually assaulted them during the
massages
just from a from a legal standpoint
from the nfl side there's already an
investigation underway
how does this play out from a legal
standpoint
i think it's too early to tell dan
because right now
the you know the nfl has not
shown the the same willingness
when there are civil suits
uh you know filed versus criminal suits
and you know obviously a a
criminal case could result in a
conviction or multiple convictions but
as of right now these are civil suits
we all remember six years ago seven
years ago now
when uh when ray rice uh had his
uh incident with his fiancee now wife
in an elevator in atlantic city adrian
peterson
uh had his situation with his son
corporal punishment situation and so
both of those cases
when they went to court were you know
they were they were investigated as
criminal cases and in those case
in those cases the nfl then can
take the player off the field until
those cases have been decided which is
what they did
uh in those cases and so that's
really what what i think until we find
out
if this becomes a criminal case and it
is uh in court you know as we approach
the season
i think there's a chance the nfl would
would put watson
on the commissioner's exempt list and
basically make it
he would not be able to play no matter
whether houston or
any other team uh would would want him
to play
so i think that's one thing to look out
for but
but i also think we basically got almost
six months now
uh before you know the games are played
and so i think a lot can happen between
now and then but to me
i think that is the biggest factor is
this going to become a criminal case or
will it just stay a civil case the
the upshot though right now is that if
the texans were ever thinking of uh
even possibly trading them well they
can't do it now nobody's going to want
to take a guy
with uh this hanging over his head so
i think uh the desean watson
uh you know future as a football player
as well as you know his future in uh
you know with the legal authorities
right now is is just very much in doubt
would you you had this in your column
though when talking to one general
manager
or you're obviously monitoring
monitoring the situation if you were
previously interested
in deshawn watson as as a quarterback
for your team
i mean would you potentially swoop in
there and try to get him
at a discounted rate because of what's
going on right now
uh that's a great question i think there
are some general managers
who would do that there are some owners
who
uh if they thought in my opinion they
could
i don't want to say get away with it but
if they could take the public scorn
you know on this that they might try to
do it
um because i don't think i i have not
spoken to anybody who thinks that
this means that desean watson is never
going to play football again
he obviously i shouldn't say obviously
but he
very most likely will but
i just don't see how you could
stand up in front of your fan base right
now and
announce that you were trading for
someone
who has got 12 women accusing him
of sexual misconduct it just
i you know if if if i were
a season ticket holder of that team that
would be really really hard for me to
swallow no matter how much
i wanted desean watson the football
player so i wouldn't expect
that any team is going to trade for him
right now
yeah that's that's certainly going to be
a fascinating situation to watch from a
from a football standpoint and a legal
standpoint regarding uh deshaun watson
and
um the texans what's going down right
now on a lighter note peter we gotta
wrap it up soon but our next guest is
is jeff bowles from your ohio bobcats
wow how pumped are you
yeah i'm excited good for jeff and good
for that team
uh i talked to him the other night when
he was on his way home from bloom on his
way back
from bloomington to indianapolis uh
i i didn't talk to him pardon me i i
texted with him
and i put some of that my column today
but what is so interesting and what i
really really admire
about this ohio team is that
it was 47 45 with just under three
minutes left in the game
they were leading virginia the national
champion defending champs
and now is when it's really
the tough time of the game and you would
think that the premier teams the teams
that have been in this space before
would take over and at that point ohio
none of whom none of their players had
ever played
in a game nearly as big as this before
never in an ncaa tournament before
uh and they came out and they made their
last nine shots of the game
three from the floor and six from the
foul line
and that tells me that
jeff bowles and those guys are doing
something right they prepare their guys
for big
situations and they really came through
in one
saturday night at assembly hall so
that'll be fun tonight to watch that
will
taking on creighton tonight peter we got
a roll thank you so much for joining us
i really appreciate the time and and
thank you for everything you do i
honestly i meant everything i said i i
love your calling i've been reading it
for
as long as i can remember well thanks so
much dan much much appreciated
we'll talk to you soon hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here